how's morale Luke it's good guys you
guys are having fun happy with the way
we're playing and excited for this
challenge of games we have ahead of us
if I told you a month ago you're gonna
start out seven in five how would you
have reacted I would have taken five I
mean I wasn't I've said the whole you
know it's the whole season I'm not
overly concerned with the amount of wins
we get early on we're trying to
establish the way we want to do things
in the way we play
but if looking at the schedule and the
amount of road games if you told me
seven and five day I definitely was
taken how do you change style tempo pace
from where you were with Golden State to
what the Lakers were when you got there
well you you commit to doing it which is
you know easier said than done and the
players the players have to buy in and
it's the only way to especially at this
level to be able to win games and play
to a certain standard you can do all the
screaming and yelling you want as a
coach but you have to have the players
you have to have the players you have to
have the talent and you need those
players to have the willingness just to
play that way in to sacrifice their
individual goals and desires for the you
know what's best for the team and at
least for right now that's what that's
what our guys that have done and that's
what they've given us now when you you
were with Golden State you had the go-to
guy with staff and certainly with clay
you don't necessarily have that
designated go-to guy but my cabin
everybody's score around 10 to 14 15
point is that more ideal than having
that guy who's getting 20
I won't call it more ideal it's just I
think it's our best I think it's our
best way to play right now with a young
group and you know we don't really have
that all-star on our roster so instead
of trying to instead of trying to
force-feed it to one person we like to
do it as a group and we like to play 10
you know personally I like to play even
11 12 we got some guys aren't getting
minutes right now that have been given a
hell of an effort all season but we play
10 deep and we play them all you know
between 20 and 30 minutes and we play a
style that is gonna get different people
different shots each night and whoever
kind of gets hot ends up getting more of
the shots and more than minutes and more
of the opportunities but we're you know
we're not we're not gonna reward players
with those minutes if they're doing it
in a selfish manner and they're not
making the extra pass and they're not
doing it in the team concept so for us
we feel like the best the best
opportunity we have to win is to hat is
to play that way where there's not one
guy getting off you know the 20 points a
night but it's just it's a full team
attack that you have to prepare for Luke
Walton they got the Spurs coming up
tonight joining us Dan Patrick show but
the fact that you were on the bench with
Golden State how does that it is their
credibility that you not only that you
played and played for the Lakers but now
you're bringing something from Golden
State and all of these kids saw what
Golden State was how does that help in
saying listen to me I saw it firsthand I
was part of this process obviously the
Warriors with the success we had there
the last two years most NBA people were
watching and paying attention and you
can't you can't do look at what they do
because they have a set of players that
is
is pretty darn unique up there but the
ideas and the style of play that people
fell in love with up there as far as you
know the tempo and the play making him
and honestly Danny we had you know the
staff and clay and and the guys that
would score those big points up there
but really we played the same way where
it wasn't like Steph was just gunning
shots every time down court and that's
all we ran in plays for and clayed the
same thing if they got hot you better
believe we were gonna run a play for
them or use them as a decoy to get
somebody else wide open but we've still
played the same style of everyone
touches the ball if you're open you take
the shot and different nights different
people are gonna end up scoring more or
less but even when you play that way the
most talented scorers
um normally still should end up with the
most amount of field goal attempts and
the most points on any given time could
you give me 10 minutes a night can I
give you to play yeah could you play ten
minutes right now
no five no chance I could give you I
could give you five minutes I could give
you what like a one from a TV timeouts I
give you every give you everything I had
I pick up a couple fouls but you you can
count on the effort that I gave you do
you think we'll ever see a player coach
the rules are on that but wait if they
change that rule that you can't be a
player coach maybe they have I'm sure
with because there's all sorts of salary
cap issues now that you can't
you know today so like you can't pay for
anything extra or violates salary Cabul
so I don't know where you because
otherwise we could start paying players
five million to play and then 15 million
to be an assistant only seen as a player
coach but I don't yeah I don't see that
we you know there's there's guys that
are like player coaches that are nice to
have on the floor you know right now two
two guys we have that aren't in the
rotation right now Jose Calderon and
Marcelo workers are phenomenal I mean
and they're at practice coaching guys
during the games and they'll stick their
head and the coaches huddle during a
timeout and point out some stuff so
there are players that are that are on
the not on the court that are like
player coaches but they cool have the
title yeah did you ever do that when did
you ever stick your head in a coaches
huddle did you just remind him that you
were on the roster and say hey Phil yeah
I'm Luke Walton I'm over here if you
need me ready to go as Kobe stopped by
he is not stopped by about I've spoken
to Kobe of the you know multiple times
this offseason and and preparing for the
preparing presented this season we had
and talking about some of the players on
the team and he played with last year
had some questions about a young Brandon
Ingram I wanted to run by him and hmm
and things like that he's been great
every you know he takes the phone call
with talk for however long we need to
for you know to get some information
from him and you know he's so he's being
great when I needed them well Congrats
so far on the on the start good luck
against San Antonio and good to talk to
you again Luke
that I appreciate I'll let you get back
to your country music dialogue and you
cannot purchase you could have a country
you could have like a Johnny Cash type
voice you you have a country voice Luke
yeah anything in career I had would have
to be country because I don't I can't
really carry a tune but if I could just
kind of talk in the background you Dan
your dad can't sing either Thank You
Luke we appreciate it
that's a Luke Walton that's first coming
up tonight Continental Tire Coaches
Corner
coach brought to you by Continental Tire
you'll see the Continental Tire at
sporting venues across the US proud
sponsor of EMSA racing major league
soccer and college basketball
Continentals premium products available
at leading independent tire dealers car
dealers mass retail companies across
North America for more information visit
Continental Tire Calm Continental Tire
for what you do the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience